[Music]
on this saturday night
the growing probe into sexual misconduct
in the military
major general danny fortan under
investigation
i think now it's just crept a little bit
closer to us in the civilian world
he was the face of canada's vaccine
rollout who's in charge
now the disturbing instability in the
middle east
but this is a flare-up that has been lit
by a match
when will the world intervene to put out
this fire
the need for nurses in canada and the
students ready to do the job
plus the future is here investing in
electric vehicles
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the man tasked with leading canada's
covet 19 vaccine rollout has stepped
down
late yesterday major general danny
fortan was suddenly removed from his
role
pending the results of a military police
investigation the government has
released few details but global news has
learned
the investigation is looking into
allegations of sexual misconduct
as abigail beeman explains fortan is
just the latest high-profile military
member
to be accused to prepare for an
unprecedented distribution of vaccines
across the nation he's the face of the
federal vaccine rollout major general
danny forte
known for leading thursday briefings on
the state of dose distribution and
arrivals
now he's forced to step aside while
military police investigate an
allegation of sexual misconduct that
predates his time as a general
my first reaction when i heard the news
was oh no not again
um to be honest with you because like a
hot a lot of heads
have fallen that being said despite that
initial shock
i'm not really surprised global news
reached forte by email he did not wish
to comment
this is the latest of a string of
high-ranking officials to face
misconduct investigations
including former chief of the defense
staff jonathan vance and his successor
admiral art mcdonald
defense minister harjit sajin said in a
statement he is
committed to working to build a true
culture of inclusion
and as for the handling of part of the
government's biggest file
we remain focused on the vaccine rollout
i think
now it's just crept a little bit closer
to us in the civilian world
lena tamsito hopes this doesn't impact
anyone's decision to get vaccinated
and she does think this latest
investigation makes the string of
military misconduct stories hit closer
to home
this individual who has been in in sort
of i guess our daily lives as canadians
and civilian canadians
is now being subject to something that
has been
impacting the the military as a whole so
i think this might
shift um canadians perspective there has
been no comment yet from the prime
minister his office pointed us to
sajin's statement and to the four and a
half million doses that will arrive this
coming week
we've also asked the public health
agency of canada a number of questions
about
what comes next and who will take the
lead but they said they won't have an
answer
before monday robin abigail beeman in
ottawa thanks abigail
now to the crisis in the middle east
right around the world
thousands are hitting the streets
in winnipeg there was a pro-palestinian
rally at the legislative building
then a group carrying israeli flags
arrived the police had to form a line to
keep the two sides apart
there were no confrontations and it
ended peacefully
but nowhere is the divide more
exemplified than in the middle east
itself
the conflict is now into its sixth
straight day and neither side is
interested in de-escalating the violence
as crystal gomezing reports
pressure is mounting on the
international community to resolve the
crisis
it's not officially a war but the images
and the impacts are the same
10 members of a palestinian family who
had gathered for eid were killed
following an israeli airstrike
a baby the lone survivor found clutching
his dead mother
palestinians say at least 140 people
including 39 children have been killed
in gaza
since air strikes began on monday tammy
jacoby is a professor with expertise in
arab-israeli conflict
there's no middle ground and so people
are being radicalized
either anti-israeli pro-palestinian or
pro
pro-israeli anti-palestinian that
doesn't really help to de-escalate
the situation there is no um
active mobilization for dialogue
peace moderation compromise
u.s president joe biden has spoken to
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
and the president of the palestinian
authority mahmoud abbas
he's expressed his support for both
sides and
for finding a peaceful resolution to the
conflict
but the militant group hamas controls
gaza
and it has fired roughly two thousand
rockets into israel
killing residents michael hemi is a
canadian
living in tel aviv a rocket just hit my
uncle's city
today so i called him up immediately and
asked to check to see if he was okay
and i think about it i think about the
palestinians that are going through the
same thing
and you know the mothers and and fathers
and families are
calling up their their relatives to make
sure that they're okay
there are and will be no winner says
canada's
former ambassador to israel unless old
land claims are set aside
and new leaders chosen hamas is not
interested in a two-state solution so
they're happy to have a bibi netanyahu
and a very right-wing
government in power in israel because
then they can point to the occupier
and say that there is no partner for
peace
[Music]
one high-rise building hit house
residents and
international media including the
associated press
that building provided the best vantage
point for the world
to see the events in gaza and now
that building is destroyed and we will
work
hard to continue to tell the world the
important events
of gaza israeli military officials gave
the building's owner an
hour's notice so it could be evacuated
saying it had information that hamas had
been using
the site ap is asking to see the
evidence
krystal gamansen global news london
turning back to the race to vaccinate
canadians
across the country provinces and
territories are ramping up the shots
in ontario the province's premier is
vowing to have every willing adult
fully immunized by the end of summer but
as catherine ward explains
medical experts say mass vaccination
isn't the only thing needed to get the
economy going again
whether it was the toronto zoo the
ogacon museum or an all-night vaccine
party in mississauga ontario
kova 19 doses were on tap right across
the gta saturday
i'm excited the push to get shots in
arms ramping up
as a steady supply becomes part of
canada's reality
i think it's possible that we can do you
know maybe one and a half or even two
percent of the population a day
you know that would be roughly 150 to
200 000 people
experts say the catchphrase from the
federal government of a one dose summer
and a two dose fall
where 75 percent of canadians are fully
vaccinated
is possible there's absolutely no reason
why we can't have
everyone who's eligible in canada have
their first shot
by the beginning of the summer still
ontario's premier is pushing for more i
just don't believe a one dose summer
it's just not good enough you know we
if we get the supply i'll put it this
way we get the supply
we will work our backs off to have a two
dose summer instead of a one dose summer
but other infectious diseases physicians
say the premise of achieving
a certain level of vaccination shouldn't
be the only
metric considered when it comes to
reopening portions of the economy
and some activities it's actually
looking at a number of things together
but with hospitalizations as the central
piece
the thought being that if the overall
trajectory of covet 19 transmission is
decreasing
with pressure slowly easing on the
hospital system
combined with increased vaccination
rates a cautious opening
could happen soon even if there is a
rise in cases when you
open up because the majority of people
or at least you know a significant
proportion of people
are immune to the virus you're not going
to see it spreading like a rapid fire
and even if you do have a lot of cases
because a minority of people are going
to be hospitalized it's also something
you can deal with
catherine ward global news toronto
some provinces have put a pause on the
astrazeneca vaccine
but more doses arrived this week they're
now being held in storage
until they're requested so what does the
canadian government plan to do with the
remaining shots
our michael couture is hosting the west
block and asked procurement minister
anita anand
that very question mike robin the
federal government received 655 thousand
doses of astrazeneca last week
but it's not clear when the provinces
will use them
more than 11 percent of those already
vaccinated in canada
received the astrazeneca dose but a
number of provinces
paused the use of the vaccine after
reports of more than 28
very rare blood clots so what happens if
there are still
unused doses even after those who got
their first dose of astrazeneca get
their second dose of that shot
what does canada plan to do with those
leftover doses
we put that question to federal
procurement minister anita anan
if your point is that if there's excess
does that mean we're looking at the
the rest of astrazeneca as a possible
donation to other
other countries as i mentioned the
conversation
about uh doses and any excess
doses is one that is occurring at the
current time
and so we need to engage with multiple
ministries uh on this question and make
sure that we are fulfilling the needs of
canadians in terms of getting vaccines
to provinces and territories
as well as our obligations to the
developing world so we'll have more to
say on the
question of donations in the future
we also asked the minister if she is
confident that there wouldn't be
any vaccine delivery delays that could
prevent canada
from meeting its goal of getting 75
percent of canadians their first dose of
vaccine
and 20 percent getting their second shot
by the summer
so that restrictions can be eased
that 75 number was determined based on
our expected procurements
so i am confident that we will continue
to bring in millions and millions of
doses for canadians
we expect over 40 million doses prior to
the end of june and over 100 million
doses by the end of september
and the minister said she hopes those
timelines can be moved up but she
believes the current timelines
are realistic robin mike likator in
ottawa thanks mike
and you can see the full interview with
minister anand tomorrow on the west
block
right here on global to mask or not to
mask that's the question americans are
asking tonight
the centers for disease control and
prevention issued new guidelines
indicating it's safe for people who have
been fully vaccinated
to take masks off while indoors as
jennifer johnson reports businesses will
just have to trust the people they're
dealing with
that they've really been vaccinated the
burden is now on every state and every
business to enforce the rules
now that the centers for disease control
says vaccinated people no longer need to
wear masks
but with no show of proof how do you
really know if someone who says they've
gotten vaccinated
actually got the shot to be less than
six feet distance
because i'm vaccinated i'm just
concerned that
the next person how honest are they
going to be
decisions on where people can go
maskless fluctuate from state to state
setting to setting north carolina for
example has lifted its mask rules in
places like stores and restaurants but
there will continue to be a mandatory
indoor mass
requirement on public transportation in
child care
in schools in prisons and in certain
public health settings the cdc
guidelines were intended to relax the
rules for those who have gotten
immunized
people who are unvaccinated should not
be taking off their masks
but now it's an honor system you have to
trust who's nearby
i think everyone's going to lie just so
they don't have to put it on big name
companies like starbucks target and home
depot say they're keeping their masked
mandates but others including walmart
and trader joe's won't require masks for
vaccinated people
nor any proof something many local
leaders agree with
we don't want this to turn into sort of
like a show me your papers moment
we'll just have to trust what people
tell us the cdc's decision came after
cases of coven 19 went down by over 30
percent last week while vaccinations are
still increasing
120 million americans are fully
vaccinated so far
while that's just a third of the country
many people are excited to take another
step back to normal
i'm fired up to go mathless i think it's
going to be good
for the community but the patchwork of
rules is confusing
so americans will still have to be
prepared to mask up
depending on where they are jennifer
johnson global news
washington coming up nurses wanted and
speeding up the programs to meet the
demand
nurses have played a pivotal role during
the pandemic many are working long hours
because of chronic staff shortages
this week ontario announced it's funding
2 000 new spots in post-secondary
nursing programs
to help fill the gap but as ross lord
explains more incentives may be needed
to entice canadians
to become nurses in her childhood 21
old sidney flores was inspired by how
nurses cared for loved ones who passed
away
now she's been accepted by the nursing
program at the university of british
columbia
i really witnessed the compassion and
kindness of nurses
and i thought to myself that's what i
want to devote the rest of my life to
doing as well
there's never been more admiration for
nurses with the pandemic forcing them to
work in unbearable conditions
they're among more than 66 thousand
health care workers becoming infected
with covet 19
and dozens dying but universities are
reporting an increase in students
applying to enter nursing schools
applications at ubc have gone up from
500 a year
to 800 and many nursing students say the
pandemic
only strengthens their resolve you hear
the nurses talking about
about just how awful it is sometimes
definitely
the nerves the nerves come in and i get
a little bit scared to jump into it but
for the most part i'm pretty eager to
get out there and
start helping out kovid has highlighted
um the different long-standing
inequities in our health care system
and moving forward i think that's
something
i would like to work and combating those
systemic inequalities facing a predicted
national shortage of 60 000 nurses by
next year
universities are switching to
accelerated programs
with our new curriculum those coming in
directly from high school
can finish the program in three years
it's three calendar years
compared to four in the past it would
have been
for what we call academic years there's
plenty of good will
during national nurses week the prime
minister and many others posted
thank you messages but canada's largest
nurses organization
says attracting enough new nurses to
offset pandemic burnout and nutrition
requires much more than kind words why
don't we just give free education
for health care workers health care
professionals throughout the country
for four six years until we get over
this bump
she's glad help was on the way but
doubts it will be enough
to prevent a health care crisis from
becoming even worse
ross lord global news
still ahead it won't happen by accident
so is canada ready for the electric
vehicle
revolution
as the world shifts to greener and
cleaner cars the big question is whether
canada is ready to join the electric
vehicle
revolution tonight on the new reality
our mike drillet
plugs into the issue mike robin it's
dangerous to say we can all agree
because
there's never 100 consensus on anything
but it's fair to say that the future of
transportation is in the electric car
that said tonight on the new reality we
take a closer look at the hurdles we're
facing to get there
and we were surprised to see for all the
political blustering and talk of a green
future canadians aren't exactly
clamoring for the opportunity to plug in
their car
it's no secret this has to end emissions
from cars and trucks are choking the
planet
you don't have to be a scientist to see
a problem with tailpipes
coughing up black clouds of smoke yet
here in canada our love of suvs and
pickups
has helped raise overall emissions from
transportation
about 30 percent over the last 20 years
now canadians
drive some of the largest most polluting
vehicles in the world
transitioning to electric vehicles is is
going to be key
if we want to get on track with our
emission targets
you know in the near term and by 2050.
so what's the problem
when will canadians turn their backs on
the internal combustion engine
so i think they're getting ready they
could push harder but i think there is
also the chicken egg problem right
if you don't have the evs on the road
does it make really sense to invest that
much infrastructures but if you don't
have the infrastructure doesn't make
sense to buy an ev
it's a quandary alexandre milivanov and
his university of toronto peers have
been studying
the biggest issue is cost even though
the number of ev models on the market
continues to grow
they still cost more than their gas
counterparts and while lower cost
options are available
to do so is also to give up range which
is the other biggest hang up for
consumers
range anxiety is very real the top end
models can go
up to 600 kilometers on a single charge
far more than most people would need
on any given day even the lower end
models that top
out around 200 kilometers is more than
the average person uses
on their daily commute yet the issue
still remains
robin microlane toronto thanks mike
and there's a lot more in mike's report
including is canada's power grid ready
for an eevee revolution
that's on the new reality tonight at 7
right here on global
up next he had 147 tickets to ride
and he took a tour of toronto at the
same time we'll explain
toronto's transit system the ttc is one
of the largest in north america
and if you add up all the routes it's
just under the length of a drive across
canada
riding every single line would take 147
trips
and one toronto team just completed that
feat
as kayla mclean reports he took that
journey with his dad by his side
most write the ttc as a way to get from
point a
to point b but not ian wellsman he rides
the red rocket
i call it an adventure for the challenge
i wanted to
ride every single regular bus route in
toronto before my 13th birthday
and so he did not only riding bus routes
but every ttc
route including the subway and streetcar
147 routes in total and ian reached his
goal
a week before his 13th birthday i took
the sunnybrook bus
to the hospital and back when i got off
i just raised my hands in the air
it was a very happy day to understand
his excitement you've got to understand
his journey
so here we are ian and his father derek
began their ttc adventure challenge when
ian was only five i've always had a
fascination with
transportation when i was younger i
watched a lot of
thomas a tank engine and then every
morning we go to daycare
right now
[Music]
i learned to say the stop names as they
went by and so it's kind of just come
from there
so great is ian's love for the ttc
[Music]
that he even penned a song about his
favorite station soundcloud have a
listen
and with ian he doesn't need a map to
get around after these adventures he's
got all the ttc routes mapped out
in his head he took the 125 drewery to
bathurst
160 backers north steel he's a
passionate
guy for ian's dad tagging along for the
ride has meant
not only discovering new places but
creating priceless memories with his son
totally bonding experience we we refer
back to
adventures that we've had as soon as we
get out onto a
streetcar all the stories start to come
out again as for whether a career with
the ttc is on the horizon
ian says he's still deciding sometimes i
consider being a tec driver but first
he'll need to consider getting a summer
job
the free rides are over my boy if he
wants to keep up his transit adventures
kayla mclean global news the free ride
is over
that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada
is regina we'd love to see your corner
of this country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching have a great
[Music]
night